[Musique]
ceux qui ont pu suivre les jeux
olympiques en 2016 doivent certainement
me voir comme ça par contre ce qui me
connaissaient déjà de l'aviron avant
doivent avoir cette image à deux mois
mais paradoxalement l'image que je
retiens deux mois ce n'est ni l'une ni
l'autre
on a souvent dit que j'avais la capacité
de dépasser mes limites je trouve que ce
terme est impropre
dès que l'occasion m'a été donné j'ai
toujours cherché à les déplacer
contrairement à ce que certaines
personnes peuvent penser ce n'est
qu'assez tard que j'ai imaginé être
champion olympique
beaucoup de projets se sont intercalés
avant rang dans l'équation complexe
l' objectif difficile à atteindre par
contre pendant ce voyage c'est presque
quinze années de ram
j'ai découvert d'innombrables limites et
beaucoup n'avaient pas forcément
l'apparence que j'imaginais mais qu'est
ce qu'une limite s la frontière entre le
connu et l'inconnu entre le permis et
l'interdît entre le possible et
l'impossible ou un objectif à atteindre
il n'a pas toujours été facile de faire
la différence de trouver la nuance entre
tous ces choix et même aujourd'hui les
doutes subsistent surtout qu'une limite
peut-être interne ou externe
mais une chose est sûre quelque chose de
factuel c'est que le limites sont
partout elle nous entoure elles peuvent
être physiologique médical sportive
éthiques morales intellectuelles
temporaire financière et j'ai souvent
imprimés dépens jusqu'à mes 17 ans je
n'avais pas du tout la notion de limite
je m'entraînais hamouri les résultats
suivent et je n'avais pas de difficulté
scolaire
j'arrivais à suivre en cours sans
fournir d'efforts démesurés pour le
travail personnel à la maison
ces facilités me permettait de jouer de
la batterie en parallèle en plus de ça
j'avais un environnement familial sain
et stable bref c'était la belle vie en
2007 2007 année du bac s'est posé la
question de savoir ce que j'aimerais
faire plus tard comme métier depuis
longtemps j'avais formulé l'idée de
faire kinésithérapeutes et je savais
qu'en tant que sportif il existait une
dérogation à la fois me permettant
d'être kiné et surtout de m'éviter
l'horrible concours de médecine
c'est vraiment à ce moment là que les
contraintes ont commencé à émerger et
que les premières limites sont apparus
pour être éligible il fallait répondre à
deux critères avoir une mention au bac
est sur les listes ministérielles de
sportif de haut niveau il allait plus
être question d'assurer un indice en
terminale es section euros c'était le
grain de sable début des problèmes
j'allais devoir travailler plus beaucoup
plus sauf qu'à l'époque je faisais déjà
huit heures 18 heures de cours
mes parents habitent et à 10 km du lycée
distance que je devais m'affranchir en
vélo bref même moment entraînant tout
petit peu moins la fatigue devenait
difficile à gérer surtout que j'avais
quand jusqu'au samedi midi
alors vous me direz rester le dimanche
matin pour récupérer du sommeil de la
semaine sauf que le problème c'est quand
l'aviron le dimanche matin il ya
entraînement je passais donc on dimanche
après midi à sieste et comme vidé de
toute substance j'étais complètement
inefficace devant mon bureau je crois
que même si j'étais un petit dormeur
je venais de rencontrer mes limites
physiologiques heureusement mon père
attentif mais je pense surtout
consciente des difficultés du moment
avait trouvé les mots justes pour
convaincre la daube j'étais d'aller
m'entraîner le dimanche après midi au
club
l'idée étant que je puisse me reposer et
travailler sereinement le matin et que
je puisse aller m'entraîner le soir ce
jour là je pense que j'ai pris un mur
j'allais devoir sortir de ma zone de
confort il fallait que j'arrête de voir
les copains pour optimiser les chances
d'être un jour qui n'est et pourtant
pendant une année
c'est ce que je fais tous les dimanches
soirs je prenais mon vélo faisait 10 km
ouvrez le hangar désert ramé seul dans
la pluie la vague le vent referme le
hangar faisait 10 km je peux vous
garantir que rentrer à vélo avec le
mistral de face quand vous êtes déjà
fait une séance
ça forge le mental des fois plus rapide
et plus efficace de passer à côté de
marché choisit tout à vélo pour une
simple et bonne raison c'est que
j'appartiens une fratrie de quatre
enfants et vous avions compris du coup
l'option taxis étaient assez optionnel
mais j'ai jamais vécue comme une
frustration plutôt comme la liberté
d'être autonome malgré toutes ces
contraintes il devenait difficile de
m'entraîner autant qu'avant et pour
répondre aux impératifs de performance
qui étaient fixés par cette fameuse
dérogation
il me fallait trouver une solution et je
crois que c'est ma générosité dans
l'effort qui m'a sauvé je dépasse les
limites physiques pour atteindre cet
objectif
plein j'aurais aimé que cet épisode soit
anecdotique mais l'avenir me réserve et
autres choses intimes de beaucoup plus
long parce qu'au final fin d'année
j'obtiens mon bac avec mention et je fus
inscrits sur les fameuses listes de
sportif de haut niveau il fallait donc
que je déménage capitale des gaules à
lyon alors pourquoi lyon tout simplement
parce que c'était la ville la plus
proche d'avignon avec à la fois une
école de kiné et en centre
d'entraînement national
la perspective était au changement au
déménagement
or maintenant avec elle de nouvelles
contraintes de nouvelles équations à
résoudre et surtout de nouvelles limites
à commencer par la limite financière je
viens de vous le dire
quatre enfants dont trois rapprocher en
études supérieures plus au domicile de
leurs parents le budget était un petit
peu limité heureusement dans le parc de
miribel jonage juste à côté du pôle
france existe un hébergement un peu
vétuste mais au loyer modéré plus
question par contre d'aller à
l'université en voulons beaucoup trop
loin
j'allais devoir passer mon permis être
véhiculé et malgré ça le temps
continuerai de me manquer je n'apprends
rien aux lyonnais j'habitais dans le
parc de miribel jonage
il fallait que j'aille jusqu'à la grange
blanche tous les jours entre le bouchon
en eux des îles et la mauvaise
circulation sur le périph ça allait
forcément impacter mon entraînement pour
rester dans la course continue
l'aventuré il allait une fois de plus
que je m'emploie 100% sur le plan
physique que je continue de dépasser mes
limites physiques et miraculeusement
j'avais cette capacité aussi loin que je
me rappelle j'ai toujours la possibilité
de franchir la ligne
j'ai toujours eu ce rapport à la douleur
un peu différent de la majorité des gens
est toujours eu ce défaut de paramétrage
ça aurait pu créer de la tension d'un
groupe surtout vis-à-vis de mes
coéquipiers l'équipe de france j'avais
sensiblement les mêmes performances que
en montre néanmoins ça aurait pu créer
la jalousie pourtant il n'en fut rien
certainement parce qu'il avait
conscience d'une chose c'est que tout ça
c'était violent mon environnement c'est
lui qui me l'imposait je ne le faisais
pas par choix mais par défaut je pense
que la deuxième chose importante aussi
c'est qu'ils avaient bien conscience
qu'à chaque fois que je dépassais mes
limites gens paient les frais malaise
tétanie vomissements goût du sang dans
la gorge
et ce n'est que plus tard que j'ai
compris que je franchissais la ligne
rouge du dépassement de soi et que tous
ces symptômes étaient le cortège des
signaux qui l'accompagnait heureusement
2009 avait rivacom le salue comme le
virage à 90 avant pas parce que du jour
au lendemain j'allais supprimer toutes
les contraintes physiques était
inhérente au sport de haut niveau et la
compétition mais parce que j'allais
apprendre à comprendre le fonctionnement
de mon corps c'était le point de départ
d'une nouvelle ère de ma première année
médecine on passa pas l'école de kiné
pis d'ostéopathie j'affine et mes
connaissances en anatomie et en
physiologie hydratation sommeil
alimentation mémorisation récupération
je soulevais doucement le voile sur les
mystères de notre vol up à ce moment là
vraiment tous et éclairé je savais
précisément ce que j'allais devoir
chercher et surtout comment j'allais
pouvoir déplacer mes limites
mais avant de chercher à les déplacer
encore fallait-il que je sache où elle
était ce fut donc ma première quête
j'ai commencé à l'entraînement il cette
première fonction c'était le meilleur
moyen pour moi de rester connecté à mon
corps l'écouté le questionner le tester
en répétant ce processus je finis par
les découvrir d'après mon expérience et
avec les connaissances que je venais
d'acquérir j'ai appris une chose c'est
que les limites quelles qu'elles soient
sont rarement là où on les imagine
parfois plus souvent - mais presque
jamais là où on les attend elles sont
cachées aux frontières du réel
à mi chemin entre du site et illusions
gueule disait fille toile librement et
essence par eux rien de faux ne survient
si l'esprit est éveillé ce que j'ai
appris c'est que sans une connaissance
théorique minimum du fonctionnement du
corps les coûts est insuffisante
il faut savoir que l'appareil sensori
moteur est doté d'un langage qui lui est
propre langage qu'il faut acquérir au
risque de faire de gros contresens et
d'être la cible de blessures dans ma
carrière se sont vraiment ces deux
leviers écoute et connaissance du corps
qui m'ont encore une fois permis
d'éviter tous ces mots ce que m'a aussi
après mes connaissances finalement
universitaire c'est que les coupes ne
s'arrête jamais car les repères changent
avec le temps il faut constamment faire
le point pour évaluer ces limites sont
là où on les a laissés lors de notre
dernière visite une forme de mise à jour
régulière en parallèle j'avais passé pas
mal de tests physiques pour évaluer mon
potentiel test à l'effort test
et tous me prédisait une belle carrière
c'est vraiment à ce moment là que
l'objectif olympique s'est dessinée
surtout que je venais de valider tous
mes diplômes et j'avais plus de temps à
consacrer finalement mon sport plus
personnellement j'avais aussi envie de
stabiliser un certain niveau de
performance
j'en avais assez de me retrouver dans
des situations que je ne maîtrisais plus
j'en avais marre de me retrouver sur la
ligne de départ sans savoir si les finir
3e ou 5e
c'est vraiment en modélisant toutes ces
données que j'ai compris que la voie
était toute tracée que j'allais enfin
pouvoir entamer et commencé de l'énorme
chantier du déplacement de mes limites
et l'entraînement eu cette deuxième
fonction jeudi énorme chantier
parce qu'une médaille d'or olympique ça
fait rêver beaucoup de monde finalement
amateurs sportifs public mais meas et
plus ont finalement conscience de la
difficulté de l'ardeur de la tâche à
entreprendre
malgré les bonnes capacités physiques il
m'a fallu déployer une volonté psychique
sans faille pour y arriver
ma carrière cette médaille d'or en
l'occurrence c'est un tour du monde à la
rame c'est plus de 4 millions de coups
de pelle données c'est l'équivalent en
fond de soulever de plus de quarante
deux airbus a380
c'est pendant des années me lever tous
les matins pour les ramener dans le
froid le vent la pluie la vague
parfois la neige c'est faire des
concessions sur énormément de
frustration à commencer par supprimer
les soirs entre potes
les hommes mois de jeunesse les cinémas
ne presque jamais voir mes parents de
l'année c'est aussi faire face à une
forme d'usure psychologique parce que la
catégorie pour les jeux dans laquelle
j'appartenais c'est aussi s'imposer 6
mois de régime dans l'année donc c'est
faire une croix sur les plaisirs
l'assiette les plaisirs de la table
je vous avouerai que j'ai souvent hésité
à abandonner à baisser les bras devant
tous ces efforts aliénant surtout que
les résultats et les progrès ne se voit
pas de suite
l'aviron est un sport d'endurance il
faut du temps pour développer les
filières physiologique propre à ce sport
il faut être patient gérer sa
frustration
ça se voit d'ailleurs sur la ligne de
départ d'une course vous verrez rarement
un rameur de moins de 20 ans en aviron
on a pour habitude de dire que les
résultats pays l'année d'après nous
savons qu'il faut du temps au corps pour
changer durablement
quelles que soient les améliorations
recherché par contre quand il arrive qu
elles vous font face elles s'inscrivent
avec une certaine forme de régularité
aussi d'abord votre stylet podium
puis les premières places il devient
même difficile à concurrence de vous
détrôner à cet instant là j'ai vraiment
cru que la vapeur s'est inversée parce
qu'en plus des performances sportives
je pense à tes deux autres améliorations
plus j'avançais dans l'introspection du
déplacement de mes limites et plus il
devenait difficile de les dépasser
déplacez dépasser tout était en train de
s'éclaircir
je commençais vraiment à faire la
différence entre ces deux mots ces deux
mots qui sont si proches dont la
consonance est presque identique
pourtant entre les deux il ya un monde
l'un s'accorde avec le temps quand
l'autre est en rupture avec l'un rend
meilleurs qu'en lot donne l'illusion de
l'avoir été et n'étant pas là un peu en
train de toucher du doigt nos problèmes
de société problème du dopage ou la
médication abusive et ces deux
paramètres là ne sont ils pas un peu une
illusion un piège qui tente de rendre
l'impossible possible rapidement
dépassée déplacer seul qui changent tous
ceux et celles que l'on extrait de sa
propre limite pour créer sa propre
liberté
le grand danger du dépassement de soi
c'est la perte de repères et la perte de
soi on est dans une situation où l'on ne
maîtrise plus rien on est plongé dans
l'aléatoire d'une réussite
alors ok peut-être mais rarement de deux
consécutives cette expérience humaine
peut trouver sa raison dans des moments
exceptionnels mais je pense que son
issue sera d'autant plus favorable si la
personne a une bonne connaissance de soi
de son corps de ses ressources et de
leur mobilisation
c'est une situation que j'ai
personnellement vécu en finale des jeux
olympiques à rio en 2016 avant le départ
je savais que je pouvais mettre des
coups supplémentaires si la course
s'annonçait très difficile
dix coups de pelle c'est 4% 4 % du
nombre de coups sur une course
c'est un risque mesuré et seule une
bonne connaissance de moi m'a permis de
faire ce choix de me dépasser
raisonnablement au delà de mes forces
mais écoute les connaissances du corps
peuvent parfois amenés sur d'autres
sentiers guider vers de nouveaux choix
vous personnellement vous n'avez pas
l'impression de tirer sur la corde par
moments ça peut être à tout point de vue
au niveau physique psychologique
professionnel bien sûr amical familiale
conjugale
moi personnellement c'était le cas en
octobre dernier
alors que l'avenir me promettais plein
de finale beaucoup d'autres médailles
j'ai décidé après huit mois de réflexion
de dire stop raccrocher les peines
mettre un terme à ma carrière c'était
devenu viscéral je sentais que ses
médailles n'arrivait plus à combler
toute la souffrance qu'il était
nécessaire dans durée pour aller les
gagner et c'est peut-être ça il ne m'est
plus grande fierté celle d'avoir dit non
non à un système dans lequel je brillais
non à ce système qui pourtant me
réussissait mais je pense que j'avais
envie d'aller voir autre chose et c'est
aussi peut-être ça la fierté celle
d'avoir dit stop avant que ce soit mon
corps qui me le disent connaître ses
limites c'est prendre soin de soi
prenez soin de vous merci vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]